so the background is this this guy named
kevin van trump he
is probably in his 50s late mid to late
50s
um
and he basically i think he worked in
chicago on like the commodities like
trading floor so he like traded
commodities but he's got a relatively
thick southern accent
right
so he goes to chicago he probably makes
eight figures trading commodities so he
like sounds like this country bumpkin
farmer but like you know he's trading
like corn futures and [__] like that
makes a lot of money
then maybe 10 years ago he starts this
daily newsletter where he writes the
whole thing by himself every single day
at this point like 17 years he's done
that is it 17 years something like that
it's like some almost 20 years he's been
doing this every day and
it makes like something like in the
world of 20 million dollars a year in
subscription revenue just to read it's
more
i think it's like 30 40 million a year
now so i've done calls with him and i'm
just and this guy who's like oh hey
check this song [__] out like that's
what he'll say
[Music]
okay so uh i haven't talked to you in
like two weeks you had covid yeah dude i
had i i can't even explain what i had i
would apologize because i missed so many
recordings but in a way you gave me
covent because i got coveted because i
went to this conference which is
you know a decision i made i didn't
really honestly i wasn't really thinking
about it code has just been so present
that i wasn't really like
i didn't do the math of like you know if
i go on a plane and i go to a conference
with 2000 people what's gonna happen
and so sure enough i go to this
conference that sam hooks me up with
he's like sam's like hey
this conference is amazing it's called
farm con these guys who run it there's
super cool story
you know it's awesome and i was like oh
i'm in and i was gonna go
and i land and i'm like yo i'm here baby
let's do this and sam's like oh i didn't
go dude i don't want to get covered
well i can't i cancelled like last
minute i i dude like i thought that you
knew that i cancelled
but like how would i know that
because we we had talked about you going
and we hadn't said i don't know we had
not really mentioned that
yeah yeah and uh i thought you knew i
canceled so i felt horrible but like a
week or two prior to
that's like when omnichrome and all this
stuff happened and it's a it's a
farmer's conference in kansas city my
you know i'm from missouri and i was
like
ooh i think that uh like that coveted
will be there yeah i don't know if i
would like it was for sure there it was
the you know the the main attendee the
main keynote speaker um dude we walked
in so i walked in
ben went with me and so um
we go in and me and ben are literally
the only two people in the room with a
mask
and there's like 2 000 people in there
and i was like oh [__] i didn't even
really think about it and i was like oh
[__] it's here um and i was like well
the odds of me getting are pretty high
but i'm now here so i gotta just make
the most of it so anyways basically i go
to this conference
uh and everything that could happen to
get covid happened meaning like it's
like uh conferences in this ballroom
great it's two thousand people in one
room all right that's not so good they
don't have masks on okay next thing that
happened i go to the gym in between uh
like the sessions we mean ben want to
get a workout in we go we meet this guy
we're making small talk and we're like
oh you're here for the conference he's
like no i'm just quarantining here
my girlfriend has coveted so i'm here oh
my god i was like
bro i just shook your hand and what am i
doing and so then this guy my gym
buddies got covered i was like oh great
and then
i get on the plane finally to come back
i'm like all right i think i might have
made it out unscathed i don't know i'm
feeling okay
plane gets stuck on the runway for three
hours someone on a plane in a closed
tube with a bunch of other people for
three hours i was like all right it's
over i got covered and sure enough i get
home
and uh two days later i get covered now
the dumb thing i didn't do was i didn't
quarantine right away which i should
have just done i should have just said
hey even if i'm not feeling anything
i've been around a bunch of people i
should just like leave but i was like
look i just left my wife at home with
the two babies for like you know four
days i should come back and help and in
trying to help i ended up giving my wife
covid then we gave both our babies kovid
and so for the last 10 days it's just
been
someone in my house has coveted at any
given time um and i've just been
literally i haven't gone to a computer i
haven't done anything i've just been get
it taking care of it ben did not get it
i think ben had it like a month ago
um
so he somehow came out unscathed did
silly get it
uh he didn't go he didn't i'm going he
flaked the night of um
and was like actually like it's super
inconvenient to get there i have to like
change my flight has like a stopover
[__] this i'm not going uh we'll do
something else so was it and you but you
were even though you're vaccinated you
got sick
i got pretty i got really sick yeah i
got some really sick for three days so
let me tell you about my coverage
experience i uh
i got really sick for three days but
it's just the flu with a side dose of
paranoia because it's like oh this ain't
the flu this is this is coven and so
uh definitely you know fever all that
good stuff whatever then the babies
everybody has kind of the same thing but
the bad thing is like i don't know how
you are but i'm like a huge baby when i
get sick me too
and my wife is like uh you know never
gets sick she's like one of those people
just like never gets a cold never has a
runny nose nothing and so even with
kovid she was like
she fought it off pretty good it was
like pretty mild you know she was still
doing that i think women are generally
tougher particularly moms are tougher
when it comes to that stuff
totally but the hard part is when we
both get the same thing and i go down
like a you know bag of bricks and she's
still complaining yeah she's just like
what is this why are you why do you need
so much sleep right now i'm like i just
can't explain
in fact i saw this meme that was so
perfect it goes there's this guy and he
goes
he goes
you know it's so good that women have to
give birth
and go through labor because now they
understand what happens when a man gets
a cold
and that's how it is i'm a huge baby
about it and she like toughed it out no
problem uh so that was kind of
embarrassing did um so how many people
how many full-time employees work at
your um
your company
the uh the the the d2c company maybe
like
seven eight full-time and and these in
amer americans full-time and you and you
like are running
not all americans but but you know
people who this is their main job they
work full-time and when you're not
counting the warehouse staff
and do you like do weekly meetings with
them and run it like a company or is it
really
if it's run like sean like very
autonomous
everything done via slack very
autonomous everything done via slack we
have one meeting a week that's in slack
and i just say hey get in this channel
right now but we just did it it's at 10
30 it's like all right get in this
channel right now and i just say all
right you everybody here and then they
just like emoji react and then i'm like
cool this is like a real meeting meaning
like don't go open 10 other tabs like
when i say something i want a response
within like a second because it's like a
live chat i was like but calls are
annoying we all agree calls are annoying
so let's just like do like just humor me
let's try this meeting style so we do it
i kind of like it and basically i just
say all right what's everybody's main
priority this week like what matters
everyone's like oh we got to do this
this this i said then i'll be like ah
that doesn't really sound that like that
matters that much can we punt that
they're like yeah i guess so and like we
just agree on here's the three or four
things that matter this week
you're doing this you're doing this
you're doing this and then it's like
cool all uh i tell one guy i say hey
check in on wednesday and everybody just
say how they're going on their things
for the week and then check in on friday
and say how did we do for the week
that's it that's how much time does your
wife spend on the company
she spends a good amount of time like
she's uh she you know she's a
stay-at-home mom i guess like first job
because like so during the day she
doesn't really work on it too much just
kind of like
on her phone in between you know just
like watching the baby but then at night
she basically works from 10 p.m when the
babies are finally
knocked out
to
2 or 3 a.m pretty much every night she
does that and she works on the business
and does the designs and all that stuff
so when you guys are both sick how bad
like who's we did no work
you just we just like you just have a a
a person who you trust and you say just
handle it
yeah
we're like you know just you do what you
can do and then whatever doesn't get
done doesn't get done we're not going to
worry about it we're not going to add a
stress to our life that like says this
week we also have to you know work it's
just impossible so let's talk about this
conference for a second because i have
been telling you about this guy for a
long time and i think that you sh you
humored me and the audience has humored
me and they're like oh that sounds neat
but
when you
got to meet him did you understand what
i was saying dude this guy is amazing
this guy is amazing and what he's built
is amazing so i want to go through
i have a bunch of thoughts but let's
start with with them okay so
the conference called farmcon and the
families call the van trump family
that's their that's their name so it's
kevin van trump and jordan van trump uh
that's like the two kind of like core
principles that's the father and son
and uh
i'm just going to describe what happened
when i got there because it wasn't like
a normal conference so a couple unusual
things i go in
and there's a normal stage like a
conference you know like they got that
freaking wallpaper behind it that's like
every sponsor's logo on step and repeat
banner okay cool that everything's
normal
but this main speaker
kevin van trump is sitting
not uh not in a chair he's got this like
mahogany desk that was put on
to the stage
and he's sitting in it he looks like a
judge of a courtroom so he's got this
humongous like oak wood
table that he's sitting behind in his
thing and he's got a gavel literally and
he's talking into the mic and he it's
just like a free-form agenda so he'll be
like
like he would just say something he'd be
like i walked in and he's like yeah
that's why i don't hire any ivy leaguers
you know ivy leaguers here's a problem
with ivy leaguers and he'll just go on a
rant there's like five panelists that
are sitting there and then he'll just
like do tell this story and the crowd
loves him i
loved him he is an amazing charismatic
speaker who is smart
and very real and he's very he's just a
very good speaker like his style was so
um
likable i couldn't i can't explain
the background is this this guy named
kevin van trump this is all from memory
i met him four or five years ago at a
conference and since then we i've kind
of brought him into our circle of
friends he
is probably in his 50s
mid to late 50s
um
and he basically i think he worked in
chicago on like the commodities like
trading floors so he like traded
commodities but he's got a relatively
thick southern accent kansas city
missouri isn't really considered the
south but it can be pretty country so i
don't know where he's from so he goes to
chicago he probably makes
eight figures trading commodities so he
like sounds like this country bumpkin
farmer but like you know he's trading
like corn futures and [__] like that
makes a lot of money then maybe 10 years
ago he starts this daily newsletter
where he writes the whole thing by
himself every single day
at this point like 17 years he's done
that is it 17 years something like that
it's like some almost 20 years he's been
doing this every day and
it makes like something like in the
world of 20 million dollars a year in
subscription revenue just to read it's
more
i think it's like 30 40 million a year
now so i've done calls with him and i'm
just and this guy he's like oh hey check
this selling [__] out like that's what
he'll say
he's like pointing at his new picasso so
i've done video calls with him and he's
got like this like beautiful like
chopper in the background like a fancy
customized motorcycle he goes oh we just
picked up this song [__] though we just
got this home [__] here today we really
love the picassos and you like that's
how he talks and he's he now his family
uh kevin or jordan his younger son runs
like this other business but in this the
commodities world this like farming
world they are gods and i've met a bunch
of people who like them and they're like
new york-ish type folks who have like 50
100 million dollars and are like
traitors and they like revere him and
they love him dude so so have you read
any of his newsletters they're so good
yeah i must paint subscribers first
they're like you know it's like it's
like a 20-page pdf so it's like not even
like a short thing it's like a long
thing and it's like he basically is
writing about what he thinks is going on
so uh in the market so he'll be like you
know
bean futures or you know rice or corn
these different commodities he's talking
about what's going on is really
important for people in agriculture
because if you're a farmer and you're
making you're growing corn you got to
decide do i hold this corn and try to
sell it myself do i need to
take on some insurance in case the price
of corn drops and um
should i sell you know all of my corn
you know in these futures in this
futures market or should i you know
should i hedge but should i take a
hedged position against what i'm
producing and so you have to decide what
you're going to do with your crop that
is your like for most people investing
is this like side thing it's like you do
your job that earns you your money your
business energy your money and then you
invest in the stock market whatever
they're two separated things
for a farmer these are not separated
this is part of the like core
thing of what you do is basically
managing your risk and these aren't guys
that have like a farm that like they
just like get by these are like folks
that like supply the corn to like
mcdonald's and we're talking like they
have turnover of 20 30 50 million
like they're here's that yeah he's like
you know you'll meet the guy who makes
all the rice for chipotle it's like whoa
that's crazy that's crazy volume and
then i would meet people who were like
what you call gentleman farmers they're
basically people who don't need to farm
they just grew up that way and they're
like yeah my family i like living on a
farm i want my family to have a farm i
farm on my weekends and nights like
there's one guy he's a ceo of a large
company
and he was just farming for fun you know
nights and weekends and that's why he
was you know like there and it was like
such a bad use of like time but it's not
it's a it's not a bad use of time
because it's a hobby it's a pleasurable
thing for him what this manual work
is like how he relaxes how many people
were there
so it's about 1500 people
and um so let me explain this guy to
their business okay so they have what
i'll call three separate components
maybe four
okay so there's the newsletter the paid
newsletter that basically you subscribe
to you pay a thousand dollars a year and
i think i believe i my guess based on
some triangulation is that that's making
about 30 to 40 million dollars a year
now in annual subscription revenue and
he's writing that you know like we'd be
hanging out it was like maybe midnight
he's at the hotel bar or whatever we're
hanging out and he's and i was like so
like you know who on your team writes
the letter he's like he's like i wish
you know i write the letter he's like
i'm going to go right up to my room
right after this go write that some
[__] and he's like you know that's how
he talks yeah he's like i don't know why
the [__] i did this he's like i created
a job for myself he's like i told my kid
my son i said you you need to the best
job in the world is investing you should
invest
don't do what i did i created a job for
myself and i have to write this thing
every day but you know you know i love
it whatever and it's really ugly have
you seen it it's like it's not mobile
friendly it's just a pdf and it's like 3
000 words with like powerpoint uh it's
all substance over style uh there's a
few memes in there which i like uh it's
like you know just some here's some
jokes uh and i think that's very on
broadcasting it's good the writing is
great the writing is really great uh and
the insights obviously matter otherwise
people wouldn't be paying for this thing
right they're genuinely getting value
and at the conference he's a god dude
people
people love this guy they they respect
his kind of like knowledge and his
content
and then they just really like him
because again he would say i literally
wrote down verbatim things that he was
saying because i was like this is just
like this is so entertaining like for
example um
i'm just gonna read you a couple of
quotes on uh that he was saying so he's
like i hate hiring ivy leaguers because
uh they're too afraid of failure he's
like they don't well they've done so
well their whole life they're not
they're not used to looking wrong or
looking silly you know go try nfts go go
go put your hands on the wheel go get go
go fall go scrape your knee he's like
that's how i grew up he's like my dad
would take us in the car he said no no
seatbelts baby that's how we roll
he's like he's like we're gonna take
some risks we're gonna get skinned up
we're gonna break some bones we're gonna
fall off the bike he's like that's how
you gotta treat your kids even if
they're smart kids you gotta he's like
because one of the big concerns is how
do you get your kid you're you're 60
maybe now and you got your farm your
kids 30 they don't want to take over the
farm or they don't maybe they want to
but they don't know how to do anything
well he's like
he's like you got to segment off a
portion of the farm let him fail but let
him have the skin in the game
um he's like you know i want to have
kids i don't melt down when the rug gets
pulled i want to be able to go to them
and say hey things things have changed
we're changing tonight and he's just
like going on this rant and dude i'm
sitting there in the crowd and i'm like
world star i'm like this is this is such
a hype monologue and had nothing to do
with whatever they were talking about
like bean futures five seconds before
that but he would frequently go on these
and every time i'm just nodding my head
i'm like preach
um like we i was at this dinner with
them
and people were
like it was kind of like these guys
organized this dinner they were paying
for it but then they as you know like
sort of
what's what's that what's the catch it
was we're going to pitch our idea to
kevin and a couple other guys who we
want to invest in it and they pitch
their idea and he's like cool so who's
the uh who's the who's the audience
who's the customer for this
and uh they're like well you know we've
done extensive psychographic research
here's a they slid over this thing he's
like psychographic i don't know what
that means man what the [__] you saying
who is the customer and they're like
it's it's not democrat he's like it's a
psychographic profile he's like no like
name them do you know five people who
want this product like would this guy
want this product hey you over there at
the table would you want this product
and the guy's like no i wouldn't want it
and the guys are like kevin you're not
like being open-minded and he's like i'm
trying to help y'all he's like i've
heard this idea ten times and it failed
i invested in this one it failed
investors and why did it fail because
there was no customer for this product
and he's like trying to give him real
talk and it was so good
and the whole time i'm just like wow
this guy's
core business instincts are very strong
and his delivery method is fearless i
just i'm trying to do the impression
because i want people to feel like what
it felt like to hear this guy off the
top of his head it's so different than
corporate america it's so different than
new york sf where everybody's hedging
every word and packaging everything and
trying to deliver it and trying to make
these [__] you know like criticism
sandwiches where you say a positive
thing than a negative thing that a
positive thing to like
you know deliver the blow whereas
he would just say
the thing
and he did it in a way that came off
great i loved it what uh all right so
you have a list of a bunch of [__] that
you've learned here let's just rattle
them off i found them to be
all wildly interesting let's do a couple
things so the rest of his business so he
tells me so he goes i'm doing i got i
know for sure his build business was
doing in the 25 million dollar range
years ago right so that so there's the
newsletter component yeah then he's like
well two please by the way i think
right and he's like you know i don't uh
there's never been a sponsor
15 years john deere comes to me they say
we would love to sponsor no trust for
the odd he he had these principles he
was like these people are going to trust
me because i'm not going to be selling
them to somebody and so um he was like
you know i'm gonna do it this way and
i'm gonna stick to my guns and so and
he's never done a never like run ads to
advertise this thing it's all organic
word of mouth one person sharing it with
another saying you gotta check this
thing out forwarding it to somebody else
saying hey you see what he's saying
about where the market's going and then
that person's like [__] i need these
insights and so
that's an amazing you know there's
probably 90 profit 95 profit like on
that on that 30 million right i think
i like what's talking about which emails
like it's so raw i think he uses
salesforce to send it out right like
that's his email service provider like
it's pretty raw
so then the second piece of the business
is i think that there's now a secondary
thing that's happened many many years in
which is like
a big company will come to them and say
hey you know let's just i'm just gonna
for argument's like chipotle's like hey
we need um we need somebody's gonna grow
soy in this region so he's just like hey
i know like they're like you know
everybody and so he's like cool yeah i
can find you people who can produce what
you need
and they were like cool if we pay them
let's call it five dollar five dollars a
bushel
you know we'll make it 550 and you keep
your 50 cents as the as a broker fee so
i think that now produces as much as the
newsletter so so let's double it
basically let's tack that on um now the
third thing
is investing so they basically had this
you know they're like well everybody
keeps coming to pitch us ag tech they
know they don't know what the [__]
they're talking about we know everybody
in this space so they then started
investing and i think they just had
their biggest hit to something called
benson hill or benson's hill or
something like that that went public um
so you know like the first kind of like
you public unicorn that they seated
and the last one is the most interesting
one of all this is what the sun is doing
so
yeah ag swag so here's the back story
that he tells about this and i'm not
saying anything private like he told us
on stage he goes
i met a guy
who he like moved into my neighborhood
type of thing
and he used to be you know big shot exec
at some company and he's like cool like
what are you doing now he's like oh i'm
uh
i'm doing this kind of like either this
buyout like leveraged buyout or i'm
going to become a ceo of
this company called american identity we
make t-shirts and hats and he's like all
right
kind of lame like
selling t-shirts now like you've done
some big [__] why are you doing that
a few years later fast forward that
company american identity identity sells
to staples for eight billion dollars and
he looks at they say what the hell is a
that t-shirt company what what the hats
custom hats like what
what the [__] and he's basically like
yeah um he's like who are your biggest
customers he was like oh yeah my three
biggest customers are cargill adm and
john deere
and he's like uniforms
what's that is that are they making
uniforms or they're just making licensed
merchandise so like i think by
john deere they're just are printing it
for form they're printed they're making
it for john deere john deere might have
employees they have you know two
thousand employees they want to say john
deere
or a vest with a giant green john deere
vest or whatever
and so he's like those are your top
those are your biggest accounts like
those are my buddies um like i know all
those guys and so
after they sell or whatever is him and
his son they create ag swag agricultural
swag it's the same idea but now they go
to all those accounts and they say hey
you want like vests and and fleece and
hats and whatever and you got you know
100 employees in your office in brazil
you need to send some stuff too cool we
got you
and i think this is going to be a really
big business also and so they are doing
very well he was saying they outgrew
their their warehouse they're trying to
you know expand and all this
he was telling me so i want to say any
of the numbers for that particular you
tell me some of just the square footage
they need in the warehouse and i know
from the ddc space i know if you need
that much square footage you are putting
out pretty crazy volume so i thought
that was amazing as well but what an
example of
just being a big fish and
not even a really small pond right it
seems like a niche but it's like
agriculture yeah pretty huge niche you
know aggregate like
my parents are working this industry and
that's why i like this guys because i
got to know them is
like the thing that people like
guys like you and me and people
listening to us were these tech folks
and we dismissed this but like literally
everyone in america has an onion in
their home or a product made of an onion
right and you you're gonna buy it
multiple times a week
um that's what my dad does my dad sells
onions and i remember people i would
make fun of him and he's like go look in
your cabinet you have stuff that i have
owned at one point i bet
and uh and so it's not as small as we
think oh i mean obviously it's not like
for example the uh the founder of square
this guy jim mckevin i want to talk
about him too he's this he was the
keynote speaker she comes on the stage
he was also a very good speaker i'm and
i kind of have a high bar for that kind
of thing but he's he was very impressive
and he gets on stage very first thing he
says is um
just want to say
thank you to everybody in this room for
feeding my family
you know it's like but it's just it's
like such an obvious thing but i say
yeah of course where all the [__] we eat
comes from somewhere and in my mind this
is gonna sound super dumb and ignorant
but it's true which is like
before this conference i really spent
zero percent of my time thinking about
where the heck the food comes where heck
food comes from and if you thought of a
farmer you probably had stupid
stereotypes of like dumb idiots for sure
i was like oh and going into this i was
like oh i'm going to go meet a bunch of
hillbilly like rednecks basically they
do talk like that i'm from there they
definitely will talk like that but they
like are wearing like a 50 000 rolex and
when i get there they're like you know
yeah you know put options on bean
futures and you know with brazil coming
on board with you know i'm gonna i'm
gonna take this hedge position against
corn and i was like oh wait y'all are
like [__] wall street traders wait
what
and i was like okay maybe it's just a
couple of these guys and i was like oh
and then i would meet guys in the
hallway and i'd be like what do you do
oh we have my family i was on a farm in
south dakota for 40 years okay cool
so i was like do you do this like kind
of like [__] soybean soybean oil
futures and they're like yeah you got to
and i was like what i was like how do
you know he said well we got a broker
but like you know
it's key to the business you got you got
to be doing it and i was like holy [__]
like you guys are more sophisticated
financially than anybody i know like i
could go to in silicon valley i go talk
to engineers or or angel investors vcs
and i could be like hey explain to me
how a derivatives contract works or
explain to me how a how the corn futures
market looks
nobody would know what the [__] they're
talking about nobody would know what to
say dude now now okay so you've you've
not made fun of me but you teased me a
little bit about like loving trucks and
farmers now do you understand why i
think it's so cool
like these guys are sophisticated and
everything but like the people you and i
hang out with in our in our coastal
coastal cities they don't give a [__]
about these folks and i'm like man if
you
got to make those collide and be awesome
right and so a couple couple things like
on that note so when i was at one of the
dinners they were talking about uh it
was the who's the customer dinner they
were they're talking about something
they and something came up they go uh
you know how long he's like how long
we've been here about whole foods
and uh you know plant-based this and oat
milk that he's like this still tiny
fringe [__] he goes america eats
cornbread and milk at scale this is what
america wants they need how much how
much volume is the whole food and then
i'm thinking dude in my bubble
everybody eats like that everybody eats
the fringe [__] so it was just awareness
of like two things one is like in the
future maybe what we're doing ends up
becoming more mainstream i do believe
that
but how not it is is crazy the scale the
difference in scale of just like you
know corn
versus you know the non-whole foods
versus whole foods is like to them whole
foods was this rounding error and i
thought that was hilarious because to me
it's like you know
it's like i don't know where i shop
every day it's it's the main thing and
again all this is going to sound really
like
dumb
but uh i'm dumb that's i guess the
answer when i was there i was learning
how dumb i was about everything um there
was so many different things like that
that i was learning can i just rattle
off a couple other things okay so
jonathan write us in the chat is this is
this i could talk about this all day i
think this is the coolest [__] ever so
i'm going to give you a couple of pain
points and or business ideas that i
saw or heard when i was there or just
making up because like oh maybe this
um
so one thing is
even though i'm like oh these guys are
really sophisticated there's no way that
they want to be that sophisticated about
this all these like kind of financial uh
products that they have to use for
hedging the props they produce and the
insurance and all that good stuff so i
think that some kind of wealthfront type
of robo-advisor that basically just does
all the work for them to manage their
risk
is
is going to be like important because
every single one of them is like yeah we
have a broker we call and we talk to him
and he tells us xyz
and uh he tells us what he thinks we
should be doing and we come up with a
position we want to take and then we
take it so that to me felt very old and
i feel like if somebody has a real
advisor thing that's
kevin trump had an idea he goes i want
to make a rally road and i think we've
talked about rally road on here which is
basically rally road is like this app
you open up and you can buy a fraction
of
cool memorabilia so it'd be like a sweet
old car or first edition harry potter
signed book set it's awesome in my
opinion rally road has one of the best
apps i've seen in like the last two or
three years super nice app
company i wish i invested in honestly uh
i've been i feel like i've been saying
that for a year probably should have
just done it at this point but really
cool product really cool app so he was
saying he's like i feel like he's like i
think we could do rally road just for
our stuff and i was like what do you
mean he's like you know just like
the the original
you know motorcycle from dukes and
hazards or you know and again i'm all
the references flew over my head he said
them really fast but like it was
basically just just cool hicks [__] yeah
and um and i was like oh that's probably
actually a really good idea because
these guys got money
and they care about this stuff and
there's like a network effect of just
speaking to that audience dude didn't i
tell you um so you know how i used to
work for the show american pickers right
do you do
i don't you were not in the market for
that because you were in uh
were you in australia at the time
whatever but you if if the show was
around now you wouldn't watch that you
don't fit that that bill but do you know
that that show america so for those
listening i used to work for the show
american pickers it's basically like
pawn stars would go up what did you do
for them
so the main guy in the show his name is
mike wolf he's the main character he
owned this store and it was called
picking and so you go and you just knock
on doors and you go to barnes and you
find old memorabilia and you either sell
it in your own stores or you sell it to
antique shops or you sell it on ebay and
like the antique shops they have to get
it from somewhere they get it from
pickers this guy like would buy old bike
bicycles that's a big market or he would
buy like a old 1936 harley for 10 grand
and sell it for 30 grand that type of
stuff and he owned the store and he
started filming himself pre-youtube for
like five years to make the show popular
pitching it to the history channel year
after year after year getting declined
finally they said all right this is cool
he's a good-looking guy charismatic guy
they pick up the show he gets he was not
rich off the pick and stuff but he was
like making a living gets rich because
he
um
licenses the show he owns he's the
producer he owned all the rights i work
at the store where we would sell the
stuff that he bought the his picks but
so many people would come to the store
that basically we sold 30 grand a day of
t-shirts and shot glasses
and because he was like eventually he
wouldn't even sell the picks anymore
because he was like i need i need stuff
for people to look at when they're in
the store and he probably made um i mean
his business was probably doing 30 40
million dollars a year off all of his
whole office stuff and when the show was
on when the show was live it's still
live now but it's past its heyday when
it was live we were the second or third
most popular show on tv
on all of tv and we would have people
flying from all over the world just to
come and look at the stuff that i mean i
would have
i helped run the store but like half the
time i was just holding the door and
making sure that we weren't at capacity
and um the reason i'm bringing this up
is this whole rally road for middle
america [__]
this is the real stuff and like buying
like these rare baseball cars or
whatever it is that's the fringe and
rally road has built a great business on
top of that exactly and by the way if
you were going to start this i would i
i'd email sam and cc me just so i didn't
get to know but b i would go to these
guys like mike wolf i would go find
these kind of like all-american
influencers
and i would use them to help promote the
app and help get them all get them on
board to to grow this thing and i think
this is kind of like
you go where nobody else is fishing i
think there's just not much competition
to build technology products
in that space um
let me tell you a couple other ideas
that were that were in there so um
any kind of fintech for farmers so part
of it's like this wealth front idea but
also just like i've invested in six
companies that are all just variations
of like you know brex or mercury bank so
basically like
there's two startups that got big that
were in the that were serving
entrepreneurs serving tech startups one
is mercury which is just saying hey
instead of going and using bank of
america or wells fargo just use mercury
as your bank right we have a slick
interface it's a mobile app you never
got to talk to a banker you know free
wire transfer but it's not really a bank
it's um they're partnering with another
bank and they just layer their branding
on top of that they're on top exactly um
but they've done really well they're now
valued over a billion dollars you know
this guy who built it mod he's kind of
in our in our friends group he's awesome
and um yeah he's great he came on the
pod so uh you know so so mercury was
bank for tech startups and then brex was
visa for tech startups same thing not
you know they're built on top of the
visa rails or the mastercard rails or
whatever but it's just a credit card for
startups and it was taking advantage of
like hey we understand startups so like
for example
you might be a startup that's raised 10
million dollars of venture capital but
your credit card limit is 5 000 because
the bank's like dude you have no income
no history no nothing no credit like you
know we can't give you money and there's
like dude i just raised 10 million
dollars i have the money in the bank
like
spend because they know that startups
spend most their money on ad spend
exactly like that or things like um you
know just the fact like hey you can fill
out the application online you don't
have to talk to human and it'll be like
sent to you in two days or like
you know you want this to like easily
autofill online like there's do little
stuff that makes it like work well for
that oh mercury for farmers
brex became a multi-billion dollar thing
mercury did and i've been i've now
invested in versions of either mercury
or bricks for teenagers for teens in
india four businesses in india for
canadians creators is the one that
everyone for creators i did that one
creators make this for food creators
this it would be it'd be so much better
to do this
yeah it'd be yeah it's gonna be crazy so
we call farmers that's what we call
farmers we're gonna rebrand farming as
the creator economy they're just
creating food yeah yeah seed creators um
dude it's so much that would be such a
better company and they're spending a
lot of money right because like all of
it the equipment the like you know this
the
fertilizers these are like huge bulk
purchases my cousins i have an aunt and
cousin who it's a mom and son
they have 1500 acres with like a
thousand cattle or so and i've gone out
and hung out with them and so they
basically raised bowls to
it's called bucking bowls so like at a
rodeo the bowl that is like it's called
that that bowl is bucking and at a rodeo
the guy
the cowboy who stays on wins money and
the bull that bucks the hardest wins
money and you can also make money by if
you have a really good buck and bowl you
get money by getting its semen out there
and all the females they kill and turn
into beef and they make a living doing
this they're i don't they're probably
millionaires but uh they are [__]
hard workers and when they walk around
places like during a work day because
like when you're a farmer you're
constantly driving to get feed whatever
they'll have 20 g's on them in cash wow
like they just have just like fat loads
like you just need or like when they go
to the road rappers and farmers dude
when dude when they go to the rodeo i've
seen them they have like a they've had
like 10 grand on them because they got
to like buy this while they're there
they do this they got to make their bet
anyway these farmers have [__] loads of
cash because they are they're still
doing stuff with cash so like
this is interesting it's a great market
yeah uh the other one if uh automation
so i think the number one thing that was
on everybody's mind is automation how do
we how do we get more automation so i
think from the beginning technology has
helped farms which is like you know
before there was tractors everything was
like you know horse pulled you know or
whatever and then tractors come out it
becomes a big deal and john deere is
trying to do self-driving tractors and
everybody's trying to do automation and
so i think if you're sitting at mit
or you're at carnegie mellon and you're
in some robotics lab and you're like
okay i can keep making like you know
things that i understand that from you
know this gadget that like turns off my
light switch in my room because i don't
like to get up once i lay down yeah so
that's what i'm gonna do it's like dude
instead
go to a farm for like three weeks
and just watch what's going on and then
from there come up with the automations
and stuff you want to pull
i've invested in a few companies in that
space um so it's automations and
precision agriculture they call it so um
which i i think automation falls under
precision agriculture that's like the
the term i believe and uh it's
incredibly interesting so like you talk
about like automated car autonomous cars
autonomous tractors is incredibly
intriguing right there's also like
sensors so just like soil qualities like
the soil health is like one of the most
important things if your soil health is
bad your crop is [__] and so
just being able to come up with models
where you can go put sensors in the
ground and get real-time soil health
data um and alert people hey this plot
in this area is not going to grow very
well because of this
that also seemed like a big deal so
those are some ideas last one is family
succession planning so
one of the biggest things was like how
do you pass down your farm because if
your kids don't want to do it and
increasingly you know kids don't want to
do it
what the heck are you going to do with
this farm uh and so there's like places
that you can sell farms so i think that
was one opportunity there's creating
your estate your will and all that stuff
there's renting it out to other people
there was just a whole bunch of stuff
around
okay if billions of dollars of farms is
going to trade hands in the next like
10 10 years
who's going to be in the middle of that
um and i think working with remember one
we had one episode where we talked about
picking your customer and we were
talking about this company user voice or
user testing which one did your mom work
for user testing and i was like i think
that's so cool because it gives people
like your mom like moms who raise kids
and don't can't have full-time jobs it
gives them work that's admirable that's
exciting that's incredibly motivating i
think you could i would easily put
farmers in that same situation
um or in that same category where it
would be really exciting and fun to work
with those guys right right totally uh
there was a couple of startups that i
liked one was called acre trader it said
these guys now they've raised like 60
million bucks i think peter thiel
invested in them and basically it's just
fractional land ownership of farms so
the idea is you can buy i could go on
there today and i could put down a
thousand dollars and buy a piece of a
farm in north dakota
and i can make eight to eleven percent a
year
uh on that thing and i could diversify i
could own pieces of five farms in five
different states i do five different
things and then there's a farmer on the
farm that does the work that's leasing
the farm from you you're just owning the
land and these guys i think the average
farm that they were doing was like two
million dollars in size uh and they did
like 80 farms last year or something
like that so i was like okay that's
actually pretty good like they buy they
basically buy the land and then
fractionally sell it off and they take a
broker fee plus they take a like
management fee of 0.75
a year on top of that just to manage the
the just to be the property manager of
the land so it sounds like this
conference is badass you you it changed
your perspective on some stuff for sure
in fact i actually just want to say uh
conferences in general i think that the
general rap is conferences ways to time
you'll see that a lot on twitter
especially from smart people people say
that
either the exact opposite for you i
think conferences are pure [__] alpha
meaning i think there's so much gains to
be had at conferences number one you
leave your routine
and that's just
frees the mind to just like get out of
the like get yourself out of the weeds
and get somewhere else
then when you meet somebody at a
conference
there's like
just meeting people in person like it's
so crazy you don't have to do anything
you know that i met kevin i spoke at a
conference and i was just hanging out in
the lobby and kevin van trump came up to
me and he was wearing cowboy boots and a
ramones t-shirt
and i thought that he was like a weirdo
like i did think that he was legit but
he was like
talking like a big game not like
bragging but kinda like he told me his
business and he had i could he had like
a hundred thousand dollar watch on and i
was like wait you're telling me he's
like yeah i got 20 000 subscribers i was
like oh sick you guys make money through
ads he goes oh no i paid subscription i
was like wait who are you so i uh by the
way he remembered you he gave a great
intro when he was introducing me he's
like i met this guy sam he used to work
for american pickers and bo and he just
gave he told the whole conference about
you and how great you were it's awesome
and so anyway i met kevin at a
conference which now you've been brought
into the fold this is going to influence
you in some capacity you're going to
bring other people into the fold that's
why conferences are cool conference is
cool secondly go to weird conference so
if you just keep going to the same
insular if you like i actually think
that going to conferences that are not
your industry
is
something that nobody really does and
i've always done like i went to i
remember like a restaurant trade show
conference and i've been to a gym
equipment gym owners conference and i've
been to and when you go you just meet a
whole bunch of people from a different
totally different walk of life you see
what are they thinking about what are
they what are their uh
what are the problems these guys are
worried about uh who are and you you
know i'm sure out of this i'll get some
investors for my fund i'll get some new
ideas i'll get i'll get some new
perspective
and it just makes you a more interesting
person and so i would highly recommend
going to
trade shows specifically but like
just different industry niches that are
not yours and just go go to a sneaker
conference and just be like oh what the
hell are these sneaker heads doing like
who are these people and what do they do
yeah i know it's like a luxury if you if
you have the time but um
if you work remotely anyways go to one
of these things spend four hours on the
floor and then spend the other five
hours or whatever at night you know
working and just work from there for the
week um or if you're young and you don't
know what to what to do don't just take
a job like go dabble go travel around to
three of these and you'll just have like
a totally different lens of things so so
i think that's like a hack
um
that you know i wanted to bring up uh
yeah it's crazy by the way these guys
the farmers the best thing i got from
them was their little one-liners like
they were one guy was telling the story
about this investment he lost a bunny
bunch of money on
people were like damn you like that like
holy [__] you must have lost a lot he
goes
it was a sad day but you know that's why
johnny walker makes a blue and yeah you
know you just like move on i was just
like i'm writing these down like these
are bars dude these guys are these guys
are amazing can we um are we allowed to
talk about
i think so why not all right let's talk
about
so do you want to give the bat we might
want to bleep out his name so let's
let's bleep out his name well let's talk
about my friend well let's let we'll ask
him after this but all right we um
he there's this guy named
i didn't really know much about him
somehow i got brought into this group
chat that you're in and in a weird way i
feel like i'm good friends with them now
even though we've only texted yeah he uh
uh
how does he
talk about what happened over the
weekend about this app
okay so um
so basically says here's his short story
he's built a couple of like products
honestly never really had a big hit um
him and his friends have been working on
they were working on a startup or
they're working as a startup for a
number of years and they're just
grinding running test after test they're
really building a lot of stuff in the
social space so he learned a lot of like
kind of the he like cut his teeth in
trying to build the next twitter next
tick tock next whatever right
and the
they were about to fail the last thing
they built the hail mary was they were
like oh let's just create this like kind
of like quiz app this like superlatives
app where it's like oh who at your high
school is most likely to you know become
a professional dancer or like you know
go to jail or whatever
and
it goes viral and it's called tbh
and it goes viral it hits like number
one in the app store because this the
flow is basically you you open the app
you start answering these questions
about your friends they would text your
friends being like hey sean said you're
most likely to x click here to see what
else he said i was like oh dude i'm
going to click that and then you click
that and then it would go on something
something along those lines so tbh goes
viral facebook ends up buying it
smart move by i kind of knew this thing
doesn't have like you know legs to
actually be the next hit social app but
it made them like you know a good not
like i i don't think it sold for what it
was reported as yeah it's
like a hundred million dollars i think
but it made you know a lifetime of money
yeah exactly so these guys they pull it
off in the end right so they went from
like literally they were about to shut
it down he's like [__] it let's just
launch this last thing
and um and that thing hits so then he
goes to facebook he stays there for like
[__] four full four years so he hits
the full vest
and he's he the whole time i don't know
he's probably bored and he's just on
twitter and he's like
he's what people call [__] posting which
is basically like you know just posting
jokes on twitter
and oftentimes making fun of the tech
industry so making fun of the stuff that
people in the tech industry are doing
and um
so anyways he you know people like to
follow him because he's funny so over
the weekend so he he basically said he
tweeted something out last week that was
like
hey i'm
working on i'm going to work on a new
project i finally like left facebook
whatever um i'm working on a new project
i want to work with a designer uh if
like i'm looking for a founding designer
if you want to like you know build
something amazing work with a team
that's built you know built apps blah
blah blah
uh you know dm me something along those
lines and when he quit and announced
that he was quitting at facebook it said
i've been at facebook they bought my app
i've been there for four years um it
really was just um there was a lot
happen and i want to give a thread on
everything that i learned any and and it
pointed down down like the down emoji
and there was no other threat that was
nothing there yeah and it was hilarious
here's what i learned my four years of
facebook nothing um and so yeah that was
hilarious and so people are like oh
people generally are excited about next
your thing
especially all the kind of like venture
investors and angel investors
this is kind of the entrepreneur you
like to back which is somebody who you
think is smart who um is a serial
entrepreneur so not their first rodeo
but also hasn't had the big win so they
still have a huge chip on their shoulder
and want to want to make it big so
that's like a great entrepreneur to
invest in and he's pretty well networked
and pretty well respected so people want
to invest in it so he tweets that thing
out looking for a designer
and then somebody else said uh somebody
two days later just tweets like
i saw uh you know a mock-up of a new app
like holy [__] it's gonna like change
everything and this guy also is like a
[__] poster this this guy uh
i think in his hands like another cohen
or something like that
and um and by the way you've seen the
the image that he's talking about he's
posted in our in our text thread before
but like you know here's an idea like i
might make this thing and and if i put
it correctly it wasn't even like it's
not a business it's like it's like a
it's just like a silly idea and it's a
high-level idea still he's still
ideating he doesn't exactly yeah so
anyways people then start memeing that
guy they're like
i just saw a new app um
new app for the first time and you know
this work that i've had on my toe for
years just went away and like you know
the next person would be like you know
uh i showed it to eight children who
were starving and now they're you know
they're not hungry anymore and so
this goes viral as a uh
as like a meme on twitter i'm gonna read
you some of them that were there the
good ones they were great they were
great let's see um
[Music]
there was guys saying like
we're happy to announce that it was
andrew chen we're happy to announce that
we just led
an uh a hundred million dollar round
new app right i can't believe they're
extending um i just got to a session
with my therapist she ended up asking me
for tips on how to get allocation into a
new company
and so just became this like meme in the
tech industry and then a lot of people
were seeing it like what's this app
and so and by the way this this idea
this like kind of like
growth hack it was accidental
a but b really effective and it drummed
up a bunch of interest and a bunch of
hype around what this new app could be
and so what he did was he created an nft
with like uh i think he's still 16
he's got oh my god he's got this really
stupid like image for his twitter
picture but it's kind of like funny uh
and he made different twitter images
based off of his and 69 of them and in
if you bought one you get early access
as a beta user to his app right
i don't know was that the promise i
didn't know yeah that's the promise look
at the floor price of what those are
so he goes ladies and gentlemen i'd like
to introduce leadership hosting club a
collection of 69
owners will get access to quote
app parentheses there is no app it is
now available on amazing
and so he links it and it sells out um
as nfts do and i think he made what did
he make off this thing the floor has
dropped so anybody who bought this i
think is probably not doing so hot um
the floor is now only 0.36 e so that's
not great but anyway it's still a
thousand dollars so 69 pictures per
thousand dollars okay not bad
so here's what i want to ask you okay
i want to ask you a question because you
have done something similar
i didn't know before you and i you
introduced me to him um i knew him as a
guy who built an app
but
it seems like people revere him like
they consider him an expert on consumer
apps
um
which not saying that he isn't he
certainly is pretty successful but also
what the [__] but but also like his
reputation like is so big where he's
like yeah is anyone that good that's
kind of what i'm gonna get yeah and
you've done a good job of that as well
of creating this like mystique uh almost
out of nothing right not that like you
weren't successful ahead of time but
like you've done a really good job of
building
what i sold my startup for less
than what my investors had put in now
you know the way it worked you know the
team still did well and i made good
money off of it but like that's not
that's the that's not the definition of
a successful business because there's a
lot of people that have sold their
companies for a lot of money we have a
we have a handful of buddies that are
like uber rich no one [__] knows who
they are and like even if they told you
that what they did you'd have to like
they'd have to beg to speak at a
conference whereas guys like you you've
got like the daily show reaching out to
you you've got celebrities reaching out
to you who want to like get on board
with you and then
the same thing because you can make it
sound good i could say i sold my sold my
last startup to amazon yeah technically
i did technically i made money but like
oh that's not it that doesn't make it a
like a huge success you know it doesn't
make me like a thought leader i don't
think that's the right way to say it
because that you you're you're acting
like you're tricking people because
you've never tricked anyone ever and i
don't think as either but what you've
done is you you've both done this really
good job of creating a little bit of
mystique about and what i want to know
is you can use the example and then you
how does someone i guess i'm asking for
myself because how do you create so much
of this like brand equity
uh like you guys have
well i think in both cases it's
basically you put out you put your
thoughts on blast so you know they're
the real answer and by the way i say
that not to make fun of the
app i think
did sell for a profit so good good for
them i'm saying i know that i've gotten
disproportionate credit for my track
record of success when in reality like
the best thing i've built is this d2c
company that i don't tell anybody the
name of that's the profitable business
that's doing eight figures a year but
like that's not actually why people
my reputation came before that so you
know that's kind of weird right so where
does the reputation actually come from
it comes from two things one is you meet
people in real life so like you go meet
you know the investors at these
different big funds or uh ceos of
different companies
and when they're talking to you they're
making an independent assessment of your
love your caliber your based on your
thoughts so right so so first it's like
a hand-to-hand combat thing you meet a
bunch of people you earn their respect
one-on-one by by you know when they're
talking about some deal they're doing or
a company they're building you you
actually contribute by adding value by
pointing out things or or giving them
criticism or or giving them feedback on
what's really great um or identifying to
them other things that are really cool
and they say wow this guy really you
know i i got a lot out of this
conversation so you do that with like
300 people and those people matter right
because they have themselves influence
and trust so for example
um
you know uh
like josh element is a good example this
guy was
he was early on at linkedin at facebook
at twitter at robin hood uh like earlier
sean meaning he was
he was like head of growth at a bunch of
these companies yeah yeah yeah he's a
big deal he's been on our podcast and so
he's got you know tremendous people have
a tremendous amount of respect for him
because he's had a tremendous career
well both and i have you know on
separate occasions met you know met with
josh and we when we're talking about our
startup and whether our startup
succeeded or failed josh knows look
you're playing in the sort of like the
startup lottery startup olympics a
startup can fail and an entrepreneur can
still be really great and
if out of that conversation josh josh
walks away thinking oh this person's
really smart and then they connect you
to some other people that they they know
and those people say wow josh thanks for
the intro sean was really great
you develop a reputation amongst people
who have a reputation so that's the
first step
through real-life interactions you
develop a reputation with people who
already have a reputation so that they
will retweet your stuff so that they
will vouch for you when you have a
project or you're doing something and
that that goes a long way in the
marketplace
uh so like for example i've had josh or
biology or different people who have
their own big following and their own
respect if they share me or they they
they say this person's great then a
whole bunch of other people just inherit
that reputation they they say oh okay if
josh says he's great he's great biology
says he's great such a unique way of
it's almost like
credibility hacking or something like
that
but that's the thing i think is
important is like
i'm telling you how the mechanic works
but there's
the thing you can't just the reason it's
not a hack is because
your your thoughts actually have to be
interesting you have to actually hack
like you're you're a hack i just mean
like you're you're you're
the uh getting the desired the the
process of getting to the desired
outcome right the second thing is we
both created content so now tweets are
mostly making fun of people who create
content and threads and teach courses
but before that he was doing it himself
right he was he himself was saying you
know when you're building a social app
blah blah or here's how we grew inside
high schools for tbh and i why did i
respect him because he released this
this memo actually got leaked from
inside facebook oh yeah yeah yeah and
the memo basically said he was like hey
guys at facebook here's some of the
stuff we did to grow amongst teenagers
and i know facebook wants to grow
amongst teens here's some stuff we do
tbh for example for every high school we
would create an instagram account for
branded to the high school so it'd be
like you know
mckinley high
you know secrets
and that's the instagram account and it
would be locked and we would follow
anybody who had mckinley high in their
profile then they would follow it you
know 40 of people would follow us back
they would request to follow but we were
private we wouldn't approve anybody's
request then at 4 pm when everybody got
out of school one day we would accept
all the requests so everybody
simultaneously would get a notification
about our account so they would all go
check it out and then they would all see
the link to download the app and then
they would download the app and then
with and then as they were downloading
that they'd get notifications that their
friends are all downloading the app
today and it felt like a big deal and
that's how we hacked distribution into
high schools
i similarly have told actually a very
similar story about how we would go get
our goal was always to get half of a
high school to download our app in one
day we did it a completely different way
but i've shared that on podcasts
different places or on twitter threads
and people read that and they're like oh
[__] this guy's smart that's a really
smart growth tactic this guy really
understands growth this guy really
understands teens this guy really
understands social and if so if you just
if i like it's that uh quote my buddy
jason hitchcock told me once he goes
you say one interesting thing i say huh
that's interesting you say two
interesting things like ah those are
interesting you say three interesting
things i say [__] this guy's interesting
and uh that's really what you gotta do
with content is you have to if you say
three original interesting things around
one topic whether it's bitcoin
or media or
robotics or whatever
if i get three interesting things from
you i'll in my brain i will assign that
tag to you this guy's interesting worth
watching and then if other people
endorse it and say this is interesting
it goes even faster so this is this is
exciting to me i think this is a fire
episode i'm not gonna i don't want to
talk about it entirely right now
because i think we should rap here
but
i
so last weekend
when you were sick so you probably
didn't see this i tweeted out about sdrs
so short-term rental stuff
did you happen to see that i saw it and
i followed what you were talking about
look super interesting your facebook
group i want to hear more about that uh
so i'll save it for another app if you
want we'll save it but did you join the
group
i didn't join the group at no i didn't
know the names it's called sam's sdr's
or something yeah i just made it in the
car like my sarah was driving and i just
made it in the car such a smart way to
do things by the way like it's gonna
sound super simple like i just made this
thing because you were curious and
wanted to learn about it right like you
hadn't decided to do it yeah
but it's
well i have now but i'm still looking
for property though but i um
sam's str crew yeah i'll let you in and
there's like a thousand or 1500 people
it's mostly all tech guys dude i've met
some guys did you get these people you
tweeted it out just the tweet that's it
only that
it's all tech guys like it's that guy aj
uh who owns uh the the pet
business and then it's nathan barry it's
marshall haas i there's there's guys in
there that i've met guys that are like
billionaires like who have sold or
rather they've sold company for a
billion dollars i met one guy who's
making half a million a month in profit
he's paying himself six million dollars
a year off of his uh a handful of uh
yeah there's another guy in there who
owns 50 million dollars worth of them
it's crazy i'm learning all this in this
[__] group it's amazing so you're
gonna have to browse through that and
i'll tell you some more
we'll start with that one next time does
that interest you
dude of course it interests me yeah
that's great it's crazy who would have
thought
about about short-term rentals and how
they're crushing it it's the highest
level of interest in me which is where
you say what am i doing with my life why
don't i do that all right you raise your
question your own life is the highest
form of interest the thing is
the thing is is that like you
you don't need to quote be doing it you
just need to have done it and there is a
world where you not quite set it and
forget it but like you just like it's
not like you need to do [__] all the
time to it right and so i would say like
one of the criticisms not a criticism
but the one uh my feedback for sean and
how sean should like evolve maybe is to
sometimes invest in some of these a
little bit more boring stable things at
least just a tiny portion of your of
your money and like this is like a
really interesting asset class have i
told you about steady
no
this is sweet i think you'll like it so
i i actually i think the website is cool
steady
i want to say it's deadly.capital or
steadycapital.com one second let me pull
it up if i just type in study okay do
steady dot capital s-t-e-a-d-y how do
most
tell me what you see it says it's a
black screen and it says how do most
millionaires build their wealth 90 of
millionaires invest in real estate study
lets you earn passive income from real
estate for 100
okay
and you invest in
okay so seti is a web dashboard for
retail investors to buy shares of income
generating commercial real estate
commercial real estate make investments
and senior financial reports in our
dashboard and get monthly deposits from
your investments directly to your bank
account
we do not offer high addressing this is
the part i wanted you to read yes we do
not offer hi this is this is really good
copy we do not offer high adrenal
investments we don't have an app
designed to keep your eyes glued to your
phone we pursue steady returns over hype
we are the tortoise in a race full of
hairs so beautiful so good so
so i read this so this guy i used to
play pick up basketball with her he was
on my like intramural basketball team he
that's got dylan he created this company
i just kind of saw his twitter and i was
like oh what's the guy dylan up to like
and i didn't even know he's a startup
guy like he's just a dude we used to
play ball with
and um has like steady capital what's
that and i read this landing page i was
like dude what is this i gotta invest
literally so i invested in both his
company as well as i started putting my
money into steady this is why you
invested in steady yeah cause i was like
dude this this is what i want i was like
i want to own i want to have real estate
income coming in
but i don't want to do the work of like
going and finding a property diligencing
it underwriting it taking out a loan for
myself buying the property managing the
property all that good stuff so what
these guys do is
they basically hand pick um sponsors so
they'll have like um guys who have a
good track record in commercial real
estate commercials they'll be like oh
this guy buys warehouses in the middle
of texas
and they basically diligence the
properties for you and then all you do
so what i do i just said auto invest so
i just say five thousand dollars a month
just as a starting point i was like i'm
gonna give it five grand a month into
commercial real estate cool over the
this year i'll have 60 grand put into
this and then it just shows me it's like
cool you're gonna be you're gonna break
even in 18 months but you're going to
get your first check next month
and
the you know basically what they do is
they go to that sponsor they say hey
you know you're going to raise money for
this deal anyways give us half a million
bucks we have this cadre of investors we
come in as one line item on your thing
and we become an investor and then you
just
like we our investors want passive
income through real estate investing and
he's like he's trying to do like the
robin hood model where it's like
robin hood made it where there was no
fee you could invest for a very small
amount of money so it's like normally
real estate has pretty high barriers to
entry for knowledge as well as the
amount of money you have to put in so
his mission is like i want to make
real estate as
you know investable for even a hundred
dollars and even a hundred dollars if
you're earning eight percent you're
great you'll earn eight dollars of
passive income and it's gonna be big you
think it looks cool i think it's a
really hard business to do because you
know you have to it's like a two-sided
market you have to have really you know
quality deals but honestly like these
aren't like
like for example with startup investing
i don't just give my money to anybody
for startup investing because i'm like
dude are your deals any good or they all
dog [__] with real estate it's like
these are like the property there's so
much data about the property it's
collateralized by the property the the
guy's got a track record you're not
looking for the next uber the thousand x
return you're looking for something
that's gonna generate eight to ten
percent a year or eight to fifteen
percent a year
and um
cool like that's doable that's not that
doesn't take a miracle so i really like
steady uh
i think there's currently a waitlist or
whatever people have to like dude i just
signed up for it it looks sick oh yeah
i'll email the guy to get you in if
people want to do it they should do it i
think it's real i think it's really good
for people uh like i've had i've had
multiple people asked invest in my
startup fund and i just say no i'm like
if you're not already wealthy don't do
this because this don't use this as the
way to get wealthy you have much smarter
paths to get there if you already have
if you're already you know a
multi-millionaire cool i you should do
this then to get some exposure to
startups but i think for most people
getting exposure to passive income real
estate is a much better
place to to build wealth if you're not
already wealthy through your business or
what
yeah that's the this is a good episode
i'm interested in city i have a whole
bunch of other topics still so i'll save
those for wednesday i appreciate you
holding down the fort while i was uh it
was hard it was hard i think like i had
to do it with ben and ben's great and
but i had then i did it with noah and
noah's great but
you and i are
i mean you're talented which i talk
about all the time you and i together
are talented and it was very hard with
it was way harder without it it was work
i love to hear it i love to be needed it
was work dude it was work and like i
thought there's been times where i'm
like oh [__] i could just i could handle
this
it was work it was like i felt like i
was working by the way if people haven't
listened to the episode you did with ben
on the silk road it's on our feed it's a
special i think it's called special
episode silk road i don't know what it's
called go listen to that i listened to
that while i was sick i [__] loved it
uh because i've been meaning to read
american kingpin for so long you told me
was so good and i'm just like [__] up
not reading it and uh so listening to
that gave me my fix and it it's like you
know the best kind of netflix shows
where after it's done you then go down
the rabbit hole and research more for
like an hour on your phone in the middle
of the night under the covers like
that's what i was doing about so dude
after that one i think we were prepared
for 45 minutes it wasn't a lot
but we were both so fascinated by that
topic and i think you
something happened where you weren't
able to come and we found last minute
and we're like let's just do this ben
and so we're gonna do another one on uh
a guy called i forget the there's
another version there's another like
juicy one but uh i just bought the book
i'm gonna go read it and like do it
that's those episodes were fun and ben's
really good at that stuff yeah exactly
and you guys play off each other really
well the one thing i really wanted to
know because while you're here i'll get
you
how did they catch him so you had said
like basically they traced his uh you
said okay he had he he had originally
posted on this forum saying ah yes hey
has anybody seen this thing and then
also
that um
that they you know caught him in the
library right down the street from you
so i got those bits but i wanted to yeah
i know it was him
yeah and um yeah like i think there was
a bunch of details about like the
investigation like that the cop chase
basically
uh yeah so basically was there more
there it was you know it's so funny
there's this episode of south park where
they're trying to like track this
terrorist and the boys are like dude
just like do a reverse google search and
like like just use google and that's
what they did and so the very first post
ever about the silk road was written
from a username and that same username
posted a few weeks prior to stack
overflow saying i'm building a website
that is trying to do this
yeah can you please email me ross
albright gmail.com
and then they like did they like used a
web archive because once they once he
once ross caught his air he changed his
username from like altoid to like frosty
or something like that but it was on the
web where like he was asking he used a
username to post about i've created a
website or no sorry he created username
it says has anyone heard about this new
thing called silk road and that was the
first time anyone ever mentioned it but
just weeks prior that same username
asked about like how to build an
exchange or something like that and then
they found out who this ross guy was and
then they realized that um
oh we just like went to this guy's house
recently as homeland security because he
ordered like 18 ids with his picture but
for like different states with different
names let's keep an eye on him and they
found out basically was like
all right whenever and so they had a
fake fb they had an fbi guy become an
employee of the silk road right and
ross or dread pirate roberts the owner
would say all right i gotta log off to
go blank they noticed that ross would
walk out of his house and go for a walk
right like they they just tracked him or
they're like all right i gotta go to
dominican republic to do blank and
they're like oh ross is in dominican
republic on vacation according to his
facebook right and so they knew the the
fbi
the day he was arrested he got arrested
in the library right down the street
from my house in glen park and they said
basically the fbi was do not arrest them
we got to get a swat team and they're
like dog he's on his computer right now
we're chatting with him and they like
tackle them right like logged in this
second we know we're having a
conversation with them and so they had
two fbi agents he was sitting at a chair
uh in the science of this library that i
used to go to he was sitting at a desk
in a chair
and
they go they had two fbi agents dressed
as kind of homeless people go right
behind him and get into a fight where
the guy was like [__] what are you
doing here and the lady was like [__]
you man you don't know like you know
like they got like a domestic
disturbance and so he turns his back and
when he turns his back the other fbi
agents one tackles him and the other one
swipes his computer from his desk and
runs it straight to the van and they
plug it they already had they knew that
he was using a pc they had the outlet
right there they turned the video camera
on and they start filming them they go
look here's the [__]
he's on the dashboard right now as we
speak here's us we're literally just
talking to him and they plug a usb in
and they like they get a lot of the
stuff out before the computer goes to
sleep and is locked
and so that how is there no movie like i
know there's like a kind of a shitty
movie why isn't there an amazing movie
about this there needs to be it's such a
good story the the book american kingpin
is the best book i've read in years and
years is such a fascinating story and
it's also as we said in the podcast it's
incredibly challenging story for someone
like me because this guy ross looks like
me right like when you hear about
gangsters and [__] they're usually like
poor often times minorities and like
well that's like the other that person's
not you know i i don't i don't relate to
that person ross was uh from a good
family a white guy a good looking dude
who lived in san francisco played on
computers had these ideals of like i
want to help the world you're like oh
he's just like me right but he's a
[__] criminal who tried to like
supposedly wanted to kill people and
sold more drugs than al capone and so it
makes you question like what's right and
what's wrong
yeah dude it's so good go listen to the
episode if you if you like that little
bit but it was really good so that that
definitely got me through one of the one
of the coveted fever nights i mean i'm
in i got my fever going i'm listening to
the silk road i got all kinds of crazy
ideas in my head it was awesome
all right that's the episode oh um we
have to do one thing before we before we
go so we um
two or three weeks
four weeks ago at this point we did a
contest on tick tock where we were gonna
give five thousand dollars to at least
one person who created videos about
using our youtube videos and chopped
them up and posted them on whatever
platform and used our clips so the end
result on tick tock alone are hashtags
in like the first two weeks got
something like 30 million views do you
know that damn um and we're giving
jonathan confirm in the chat are we
giving it two to the people that i think
it's the cartoon let me know but the
first guy that we're yeah okay and it's
the the first guy we're giving it to his
name on tick tock i believe was mfm
minis i think his name is michael and he
posted a bunch of videos a few of them
got more than a million views his msm
cuts right i'm sorry is it oh yeah i
can't get that wrong because there's an
mfn minis as well jonathan tell me
exactly who the winner is in the chat i
can't get that wrong
mfm cuts is the winner
and this person got something like so
mfm cuts that's the winner mfn cuts
that's the winner this person got like
30 000 followers on their tick tock
channel in like 10 or 15 days millions
of views they won and then the second
place person who also gets five thousand
dollars i think they're called um
toon pods is that what they're called
say it again pod tune mr pod tune so
they turned podcasts into cartoons like
south park style we've retweeted a
couple of them because they're awesome
and they are hilarious they are really
good so the best one was where i was
making fun of you for not wearing a
shirt hilarious really good i have a
feeling both of these guys are gonna end
up making a lot of money by uh turning
this into a business and i bet they
already have
yeah exactly um good job good job by
them
by the way mfm cuts the guy he is in
university still when i emailed them
he's 19.
i love it uh good job by them and so can
are is this still going can people still
end like win next month a different like
a different person could win or no yeah
we're gonna keep doing it we gotta wait
i gotta wait till jonathan tells me
we're allowed to announce it but we are
going to continue doing it because we
saw uh in december our podcast basically
in november we were like just shy of a
million in december we basically skipped
over a million and went straight to two
million and i think that that tick tock
thing was one of the reasons why it
happened one of a couple reasons yeah
and did we do this other winner two the
60 minute thing
we'll announce that next time okay
sounds good uh all right i gotta go good
stuff good seeing you again all right
i'll touch that episode
[Music]
you